Jamal Adams jets safety once out of New
York he had I think a very creative
approach last night he sent a message on
Twitter to fellow safety Marcus Mei who
arrived in the NFL the same year he did
and in the message he said to Marcus man
I'm gonna miss balling with you the most
which is it's almost like he's trying to
his feet them a light I suggested last
night speak a trade into existence he's
just acting like he's not gonna be back
now Chris I don't know that that's the
best approach because I think one of the
things that will help the Jets get their
best possible trade offer is to make
people think that they are going to keep
Jamal Adams so there's a certain point
where Jamal Adams has to maybe cooperate
with that process although it didn't
keep Stefon Diggs from being traded it
didn't keep Jalen Ramsey from being
traded it didn't keep Antonio Brown from
being traded so you know Jamal Adams
wants out there are eight teams that he
reportedly is interested in or would be
willing to be traded to uh although I
think at the end of the day he would be
willing to trade and be traded to anyone
but the Jets I just think he doesn't
want to play for the Jets anymore your
thoughts on how it got to this point and
and just as a preliminary matter whether
it's even salvageable is there a way to
fix this and should the Jets want to fix
it I do think it's salvageable I do I
think you know the things I know about
I've been around Jamal Adams a few times
first off he's an intense you know
intense guy loves football you can feel
the intensity of the human being when
you're around him he loves talking to
sport he's very passionate no he works
hard always hear those type of things
from people in the Jets organization can
he go off the handle on a given day
maybe in the facility and be a little
distraction yeah he can though those are
the things that I've been told through
the grapevine you know and and I get
that listen there's a lot of players in
the NFL or like that there's a lot of
great players in the NFL that are like
that you know they wear their emotions
on their sleeve so it's tough so I don't
think it's broken yet I think the
biggest thing - for me is hey Jamal
Adams is clearly the best safety in
football as you've heard me say and I do
think he is one of those guys that oh no
he's not just like the next guy
so he deserves to be the highest-paid at
the position he is clearly the most
talented he is a focal point of any
defense and he should be paid like the
highest-paid guy in football at that
position the big thing is Mike with with
it to me you know I just think we're too
late into the game into the offseason
like I don't see long term contracts
happening in this type of situation I
don't see trades happening right now in
this type of situation in the current
environment we are I mean are you really
gonna be a team you know right now with
the uncertainty of this year and maybe
even next year if you're being realistic
about what's going on that you're gonna
trade away assets or give away money or
a new contract and all those things I
just think there's a lot of moving parts
so I'm hoping it's salvageable I love
Washington play he's the best player on
the New York Jets but I do think he's
dancing a very fine line of you know
dancing his butt out of favor with the
Jets all together where they do want to
just get him out of there and apparently
he gets his trade he won't be insisting
on the long-term deal that he's been
insisting on from the Jets but yeah just
because the Texans did it with Laremy
Tunsil and the Rams did it with jaylen
Rams he doesn't make it right to give up
major assets for a guy in trade and not
sign him to a new contract ASAP you give
the guy more leverage in your contract
talks once you have made this gigantic
investment in getting him for the Texans
it was a couple of first-round picks now
they also got Kenny Stills but Laremy
Tunsil was the centerpiece of that trade
and he had great leverage he did a
three-year 66 million dollar contract
earlier this year because they didn't
get him to do a contract on the way in
the door Jalen Ramsey what in the world
of the Rams gonna do they gave up two
ones in a four and he's got all the
leverage so I mean you know III agree
with what you're saying here although
it's not unprecedented that he would be
traded without a new contract I don't
think this is some new trend right they
say it's a copy League this is something
you do not want to copy do not copy the
Texans and the Rams when it comes to
giving up multiple first-round picks and
not getting an extension on the way
through the door and so and the other
side of it too is to the extent that the
word is out that you
Jamal may be a little temperamental and
maybe a little hard to handle yeah is he
suddenly gonna change when you have him
on your team and and you you better have
a plan in place on every coach thinks I
can deal with that well it's easy to say
I can deal with that until you have to
deal with that and and and look I he I
think he's one of the players it's good
enough that you justify if the yeah
because like you said plenty of players
are temperamental
when he's one of the best players in
football you find a way to look the
other way like coaches and organizations
have done over the year I repeatedly
right that's exactly right and I think
you know the other thing and I'm really
more times than not teams appreciate
that type of passion but they just don't
like when it filters over to social
media or being said on you know the
biggest radio station here in the New
York area where he's made a few
controversial comments or moments there
that have certainly you know got a
little rise and the reaction of the Jets
fans and the Jets organization you know
those things like you can deal with it
but you don't want to deal with it for
the most part if you're an organization
you'd like the leader of your team to be
a guy that's always positive and
everything like that but here's like the
other angle bike that I just I worry
about with even for Jamal Adams I worry
about the player like the Yannick and
Gok way effect right like don't start
talking to yourself like you're out of
town and I'm getting out of here and I
don't want to be here and start hurting
the Jets ability to get good trade value
for you to now where yes you've made it
so clear that you don't want to go back
that you backed the organization to a
corner to where they're gonna go
we'll wait now that you've done this and
caused such a stir
you're you're lessening you know our
ability to get a trade a great trade
value for you and now we're gonna be
hold steadfast and sit here until we
feel like that value is gone up and I
think he's gonna worry about that too
here so you can't be too controversial
and too out there saying you want to get
out there because you're gonna upset the
people with the Jets and they're not
gonna get what they want this better and
also and look a lot of this stuff some
will say it matters some will say it
doesn't matter but the CBA has been read
configured to make it harder to hold out
it's more expensive now it's $50,000 a
day in training camp and also it used to
be a guy had to show up within 30 days
before the start of the regular season
to get his credit toward free agency for
that year under the new CBA if you just
fail to show up for the start of camp
you'd lose your credit toward free
agency we have seen guys not care about
it like Aaron Donald like Ezekiel
Elliott last year like Chris Johnson
several years ago because at this point
the goal is to get a contract not to get
a year of credit toward free agency but
Ferg I like Jamal Adams who's got three
years of service and needs one more to
bet have credit for free agency if he
doesn't show up on time this year he
doesn't get that fourth year but he's
still under contract for two more so you
know I I I mentioned all that because we
have to take seriously the possibilities
gonna hold out and you know this is this
is the annual point in the calendar
where I mentioned for the first time I
don't want to hear people say he's
signed a contract there are two
contracts that apply his contract with
the team and the league's contract with
the Union and under the league's
contract with the Union he has rights to
withhold services under certain
circumstances it's just more difficult
now than it used to be under that
contract but he does have the right to
not show up if he choose to do so for
strategic reasons or for any reason so
yeah he's done if in his mind the bridge
has been crossed and burned with the
Jets now can that bridge be rebuilt do
the Jets even want to rebuild it see
that's the other thing that we don't
know I know we don't know that it's
gotten to this point do the Jets it's
it's like is it really worth it we saw
and I mentioned this on Friday when big
cat and I talked about it Adam GaSe
entering his last year as coach of the
Dolphins Jarvis Landry gone and DOMA can
suit GaN Mike pounce he gone and I think
to a certain extent 95% of his problems
were coming from 5% of his roster and he
just you know you want guys who want to
be there yeah the problem is if you let
everyone who says I want out go you have
created an easy path out of the maze you
know those mazes that they used to put
in the newspaper you can't fit this is
an easy path doors here doors here
straight line all I got to say is I want
to be here so that's the challenge for
them you don't want to
create a precedent makes it too easy to
let guys leave but you also don't want
somebody who doesn't want to be there
because you need a locker room full of
guys who want to be there Chris yeah
well I I mean it's a delicate situation
it's a big year for the Jets I mean we
know that right I think it's a big year
for Adam GaSe you know a lot of people
within the organization
you don't want a lot of distractions
going on with your football team and
listen quite honestly if you're a Jets
fan or a member of the Jets organization
you'd like Jamal Adams to be on your
team in a crucial year especially I
think if you're Adam GaSe who's you know
a guy that like we said this is a big
year for his career and whether he wants
to continue to be the head coach of the
New York Jets and everything like that
jamal adams is the best player on the
Jets football team he's the best the
biggest difference maker they got on the
defensive side of the ball so I would
have a hard time believing that you
can't mend this bridge and build it back
together if they found a way to make him
15 million dollars a year big money
something like that he would be the guy
I think you can deal with a little of
this stuff going on because he's so
talented you don't want to let a guy
like this you know out of your locker
room off your offer team if we stipulate
for the purposes of this conversation
that he is the best safety right now in
football here's what I'm trying to
understand yeah on the scale of best at
their position from best quarterback
down to best long snapper where does
best safety fit as it relates to the
priority that we have to keep he's the
best safety we have to keep him how I'm
good question having the best safety
versus having the best quarterback or
having the best long snapper where is it
on that spectrum that's a great question
I think it's in this day in the modern
day NFL it's pretty high up there bike
you know okay we know quarterbacks won
you know what's after that tackle and
pass rusher right we'll say that's two
and three somewhere in there whatever
order you want to put it in safety this
day and age in the NFL with all the
great tight ends all the offenses who do
things at the line of scrimmage
Jamal Adams fits like more than one
position that's the beauty of these type
of guys so you know I think you could
argue and sit here ago know this you
know safety a guy like Jamaal Adams is
in the conversation for maybe one of the
fourth or fifth most position important
positions and all the sport right now
you see a guy like Bill Belichick every
year he's collecting them safeties
because of their ability to match up
with different guys backs out of the
backfield slot receivers the George
kindles and Travis Kelsey's of the world
hey now you've got a thought buff fill
the B gap and attack a tackle Ezekiel
Elliott like you're a linebacker those
are rare guides and a Greg Williams
defense that asks a lot of the safeties
and really knows how to utilize them
that's where I think he's very very
important and yeah that's where I can
understand them wanting to pay him big
money and not let a guy like that out of
the out of the organization sixth
overall pick in 2017 and we we mentioned
various franchises when it comes to the
could have had Patrick mahomes or
deshaun Watson conversation in fairness
to the likes of the Chicago Bears I
think we need to point out the Jets
could have had Patrick mahomes
the Jets could have had two Shaun Watson
instead of Jamaal Adams and how
different things coordinating producer
Matt Casey just said something in my ear
that I don't think he wants me to
actually repeat verbatim on the air
he's a Jets fan
so anyway I think that that's part of
this too now big Kent and I talked on
Friday about the fact that the GM now
Joe Douglas has no attachment see it's
harder for Ryan pace with Mitchell true
Biscay because right he's the guy in
Chicago who drafted the guy at number
two traded up to get him and left my
home's into Shawn Watson on the board
and it's apples to apples at quarterback
Joe Douglas can just say well this is
Mike mckagan ins problem I don't feel
like I have to make this work I feel
like I can take this asset that we have
and and flip it for whatever the best
answer is that that we can get and
there's not that emotional attached
you would have to step away from as the
guy that drafted Jamal Adams so I think
that's my actor to Mike realistically I
mean when do you think we're gonna see a
trade or a new big contract in the NFL
anytime like when's the next time do you
think we're gonna see that like I don't
think we're gonna see it until we're
like we know there's a games about to be
played like I just don't think it's
gonna happen until we get a little
farther down the road I think teams are
gonna be very reluctant to do any of
that kind of stuff there are more than a
dozen guys who have been tagged this
year and who are in that July 15 window
to do a long-term deal or not I would
just like to think that with that many
different teams involved then at least
one of them is going to say we're
comfortable we're more comfortable with
the financial uncertainty of signing
this guy to a long-term deal then we are
comfortable knowing that we're gonna
move to year 2 of this year to year
proposition that allows a guy to move on
in year 3 potentially because we really
want this guy to be around so one of
those teams is gonna do it I think so
we'll see something by July 15 trades I
don't know I think we got to get the
training camp
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports